so we've been covering and talking about
these tragic
major mass shootings over the last week
in the united states
one of them took place in colorado and
as if we needed
any kind of reminder about the
pernicious and depraved nature of the
nra the national rifle association
consider that the nra bragged that it
helped
block a ban on ar-15s and high-capacity
magazines in boulder colorado
just days before a shooter
with exactly that type of firearm
killed 10 people in boulder at a grocery
store
think about that the nra bragging about
that
and after the shooting the nra actually
tweeted a defense of the second
amendment
if you can imagine anything more crass
and poorly timed
although maybe for them it's exactly the
right time to tweet this stuff saying
quote
a well-regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed
they are bragging about their role
in blocking a boulder colorado ban
on the exact type of weapon that six
days later was used for the shooting
and the nra tweeted about a decision uh
made in boulder quote a colorado judge
gave law abiding gun owners
something to celebrate he ruled that the
city of boulder's ban
on commonly used ar-15s and 10 plus
round magazines
was preempted by state law and struck
them down this was a ban passed by the
boulder city council
unanimously in 2018 they passed in 2018
an assault weapons ban and a high
capacity magazine
ban after the marjory stoneman douglas
school shooting in parkland florida
it has gone through appeals
and this fight and now the nra
celebrates we got him back the ar-15s
and then six days later one is used in
boulder colorado to kill 10 people and
what we have to remember and understand
is i mean listen first of all there is
no more depraved and backwards
organization in the u.s
than the national rifle association
maybe the republican party
but one of the most depraved and
backwards organizations
but you have to understand that the nra
is a business
lobby okay the who are the customers of
the nra
it's not the gun owners it's the gun
manufacturers
and the gun manufacturers make money by
selling guns democratic presidents
help to sell guns because the nra will
claim
that these democrats are going to come
and take your guns under barack obama
under the threats from the nra under the
announcements from the nra
that barack obama was a threat to your
gun ownership we saw record gun
sales under donald trump who was not
caricatured as the president that will
take your guns gun sales actually
declined
the other aspect of this and this is
you know it's just a reality mass
shootings
also sell guns for two reasons number
one
the nra comes in and says look at how
dangerous the world is out there
partially because the nra
has been so successful it's really
dangerous out there
you need guns and then so people go and
then they buy more guns
and then of course mass shootings also
sell guns
because after the mass shooting groups
like the nra and other gun rights groups
will say this is not the time for
democrats to come take your guns which
they want to do
which perpetuates people wanting to go
and stockpile
even more firearms and ammunition so as
i said earlier today
we have a second amendment i don't
dispute that my left leaning
gun owning friends don't dispute that
many of us on the left
have actually armed ourselves during the
pandemic
partially for fears that you know if
these supply lines for
i mean okay toilet paper but maybe more
critically uh other other items medical
elements
uh food whatever um if if the supply
lines are interrupted for longer periods
of time
many on the left saying i don't want the
right wingers to be the only ones with
the firearm so this is not about
contesting that there's a second
amendment or whatever
this is about the pernicious and
depraved nature of groups like the nra
whose answer is always more guns their
primary thing is
let's prevent bans on any types of
firearms and then their secondary thing
is
if it's safe out there we say it's safe
because of guns if it's dangerous out
there we say well you need more guns
if there's a democratic president
they're coming for your gun so you
should get them now
the answer is always more guns for the
nra
and it's hard to imagine at this point
um a more immoral organization
there probably are some but i'm
struggling to think of them